[Musique]
direction canada a plus ou moins deux
heures de nouméa la capitale
à l'embranchement de fond harry tourner
sur votre droite puis traversez farineau
et sarraméa
tribu de petits coulis passer le col
d'agnes mieux vous tend ses bras et vous
accueille avec ses quelque
380 virage
votre traversée sera agrémentée de jolie
cascade et d'aires de repos qui vous
permettront de reprendre vos esprits
avant d'arriver au vent fin au bout de
ce col fantastique
bref
vous êtes bien perdu
bienvenue en brousse
c'est jour de rentrée des classes et la
petite école maternelle du village
accueille aujourd'hui une quarantaine
d'enfants originaire des tribus de la
commune maîtresse anne il fait également
sa première rentrée et elle accueille
parents et enfants
mesdames et messieurs chers parents
bonjour je suis mettrait ce âme je ne
suis pas d'ici et je fais ma première
rentrée des classes je vais donc vous
demander de bien vouloir avancer et on
va se mettre en rang pour entrer en
classe allons-y on se range on se range
mais rangé vous met 2 par 2 me ranger
vous mais wang li na wan de l'ina vient
voir personne ne vient se ranger les
enfants me regarde avec des gros yeux et
ça court dans tous les sens comme ça va
pas être facile
attend maintenant je vais t'aider même
qu'un manga
faesch 1 fâcha
chabat jours j'aime bajoues famille la
famille voilà c'est bon
ou merci beaucoup bien on va pouvoir
entrer en classe et vous allez vous
asseoir allez on s'assoit asseyez-vous à
6 mai asseyez-vous mai mais pourquoi
est-ce que tu plus rejeter juste demandé
de t'asseoir home et bruno lina buengo
li na vient voir
personne ne m'obéit personne ne m'écoute
j'ai jamais vu d'enfants aussi insolent
et aussi indisciplinés
c'est du n'importe quoi fais quelque
chose
à mais tu sais ici les enfants touchés
il parle pas très bien français et ils
comprennent même pas comme à la maison
il ya personne qui leur parle en
français
mais là quand tu leur parles c'est comme
si que tu leur parles en chinois tu vois
cette histoire est inspirée de faits
réels
en 2015 j'ai eu ma première affectation
en tant que professeur des écoles dans
une école élémentaire en brousse dans ma
classe il avait 21 élèves dont 16 avec
des mentions spéciales dans leur dossier
demande de bill orthophonique en attente
manque de lait site manque de structures
grammaticales avec un gros attention en
rouge en gras et en majuscules
manque d'outils pour communiquer
manque de culture générale ou encore vif
mes expressions peu pertinente
bref la panoplie du futur élève en échec
scolaire
la plupart d'entre eux avaient un ppr
est ce un plan personnalisé de réussite
scolaire en gros chacun avait la liste
de ces difficultés écrite noir sur blanc
5 seulement n'avait pas de ppr s ils
étaient pour ainsi dire normaux ou
plutôt anormaux
le contexte le monde à l'envers
j'ai trouvé ça suffisamment étrange pour
interroger mes collègues la première
réponse que j'ai eu il parle tellement
la langue maternelle attributs que à
l'école ils comprennent plus rien
deuxième réponse ça fait des années
qu'on a mis orthophoniste ni psychologue
scolaire alors tu sais on a beau signal
et rien ne changera et enfin une réponse
qui m'a scié les conseillers
pédagogiques et l'inspecteur ne passe
qu'une seule fois par période alors ne
t'inquiète pas rempli bien les papiers
et ça ira
en 2010 j'ai fait un master en français
langue étrangère c'est-à-dire pour
enseigner le français à des non
francophones j'ai pensé que ça pouvait
être utile pour les enfants d'ici il
faut savoir qu'en nouvelle calédonie il
y à plus d'une vingtaine de langues
locales
si bien que moi même qui suis kanak je
peux facilement me trouver comme une
étrangère ne maîtrisant pas la langue du
coin
l'enseignement se fait donc en français
qui est la langue de scolarisation
pendant mes études j'ai appris à
enseigner le français à des étudiants
étrangers à des gens du voyage et à des
enfants nouvellement arrivés en france
à mon retour quand j'étais à l'iufm
c'est-à-dire l'institut qui forme les
futurs professeurs des écoles j'ai
constaté qu'il n'y avait aucun module
qui traitait du français a enseigné
comme une langue seconde voire comme une
langue étrangère
les enfants qui ne maîtrisent pas la
langue de l'école et qui donc ne
comprennent pas les enseignants seront
de toute évidence et par simple
prophétie auto-réalisatrice pour
certains en tout cas en échec scolaire
tout au long de leur scolarité
ils seront les futurs décrocheurs du
collège les futurs jeunes délinquants
les futurs troubles heures de l'ordre
public voir les futurs voleurs de
voitures
soit dit en passant ils réussiront à
déjouer les systèmes d'alarmés plus
sophistiqués
et tout ça sans diplôme pas si bête que
ça en fait
mais comment accepter cet effet de
gaulle m l'effet de golem vous
connaissez
c'est quand on vous dit que vous êtes
nuls et que finalement vous y croyez dur
comme fer et donc vous le devenez nul en
2016 avec ma collègue de lanthane at on
a mis en place un projet de co
intervention la cua intervention c'est
quand on mène une séance en tandem les
élèves reçoivent le message dans les
deux langues et ils nous répondent dans
la langue dans laquelle ils se sentent
le plus à l'aise et c'est souvent sans
faute
notre inspecteur a validé le projet et
d'autres collègues ont rejoint l'
aventure
seulement il en faut toujours un ou une
pour critiquer
aucune utilité on est là pour enseigner
le français et en français en plus ça
nous bouffe du temps sur leur est alors
en finira jamais programme et puis moi
je n'ai pas envie qu'une collègue entre
dans ma classe
mais au bout de deux périodes les
résultats se font sentir les familles et
les élèves sont plus présents et plus
impliqué alors l' aventure se poursuit
et un jour une collègue vient nous voir
et nous dit votre projet en coin
intervention directe ça marche bien
j'aimerais rester dans ma classe
bingo une nouvelle illuminé je dis ça
mais c'est quand même malheureux de me
croire illuminé alors que depuis 1953
l'unesco encourage l'enseignement en
langue maternelle
bref
en équipe on décide que les classes de
grande section cp et ce1 bénéficie de la
cua intervention bon on a tout de même
eu quelques parents réticents ça fait
des années qu'on nous interdit à nous et
à nos parents d'utiliser et de parler la
langue dannatt et là vous voulez
l'utiliser pour apprendre le français
non mais il faudrait choisir
mais finalement ils nous ont rejoints
comme une maman
maîtresse mon fils m'a dit que les cours
avec pas et maîtresses claudia c'était
plus facile et c'était très bien
[Musique]
comme un enfant ben ceux qui vont avec
les deux maîtresses ils ont toujours
tout juste alors moi aussi j'ai envie
d'aller avec eux
et bilan fin d'année les résultats sont
positifs
climat scolaire très bon moins de
violence très peu d'absentéisme aussi
bien chez les élèves que chez les
enseignants et ça c'est un très très bon
indicateur
alors on a proposé d'organiser les
évaluations en passant les consignes
dans les deux langues les élèves
pouvaient nous répondre dans la langue
dans laquelle il se sentait le plus à
l'aise mais là l'inspection n'est pas ok
le protocole c'est le protocole tout
doit se faire en français
heureusement notre directrice nous
autorise à passer les consignes dans les
deux langues
tout ça en secret bien sûr
et là miracle
dans cette zone qu'on pourrait est
classé comme zone d'éducation
prioritaire les résultats passent de 11
à 25 en grammaire de 14 à 25 en
orthographe et de 0 à 15 ans géométrie
c'est déjà un très bon début en plus de
ça les élèves jubilé souri en entendant
les consignes dans les deux langues
envoient leurs visages qu'ils ont
compris et au moment de répondre à
l'oral comme à l'écrit très peu de
blocages et beaucoup d'assurance
avec tout ça on a créé mutualiser des
outils pour permettre à chaque
enseignant de faire entrer dans sa
classe la langue et la culture de ses
élèves affichage des consignes des sont
dénombrés de l'alphabet en langues kanak
utilisation des deux langues pour tous
les supports dans toutes les matières et
pour toutes les classes pour les
nouveaux collègues qui n'étaient pas du
tout formés à la cua intervention
c'était très utile dans ce clip du
nouveau tout est écrit et prêt à
l'emploi
cette expérience en brousse m'a
totalement convaincu si bien que j'ai
décidé de me lancer dans la recherche
action sur ce sujet car je ne supporte
plus que le système scolaire fabrique
lui-même l'échec scolaire sans même
qu'ils s'en rendent compte
[Applaudissements]
alors oui à court terme la cua
intervention un coup ça coûte cher de
mettre deux enseignants dans une même
classe mais si la couette invention est
mise en place dès la maternelle on
pourra sont passés dans les classes
suivantes
quel est le coût financier
et quel est le coût humain
d'un système scolaire défaillant devenu
presque spectateurs du naufrage de nos
jeunes
l'aco intervention c'est un outil pour
sauver notre jeunesse
lacombe intervention c'est un placement
un placement pour l'avenir et un
placement pour nous tous au les quatre
fois merci
[Musique]